[Musica]
al ritorno dall ultimo viaggio in india
con mio figlio
stavamo aspettando il prossimo volo al
prossimo aereo ea un certo punto
guardavamo un po stavamo rovistando
nella borsa che ci avevano dato le
hostess del volo prima è una borsa tipo
questa è proprio quello tipo quella che
avete che avete voi
e mentre cercavamo lo vi stavamo datemi
una mano provate anche voi nella vostra
borsa a cercare è un certo punto abbiamo
trovato un palloncino
non so se l'avete trovato anche voi c'è
ma guarda e allora mentre ci siamo a un
certo punto messi a gonfiare questo
palloncino cominciavamo a gonfiarlo per
pensare cosa farne a un certo punto
preme mio figlio si ferma con aria
seriosa mi guarda e mi dice papà ma lo
sai che i paesi meno ricchi scervellano
molto di più e io ma premer vuoi dire
cervella know how scervellano no no no
no scervellano ma in che senso
beh perché sai in effetti a pensarci
bene loro devono e lui continuava ancora
a gonfiare palloncino e ogni tanto sai
loro devono fare tanto con poco devono
inventare applicare delle tecnologie per
risolvere dei problemi che per loro sono
molto molto grandi
in effetti a pensarci bene se ci
pensiamo bene le tecnologie e le
innovazioni che hanno avuto più successo
sono quelle che alla fine hanno
affrontato e risolto delle sfide che
erano il più possibile globale però
queste sfide sono sfide che alla fine
sono quasi ciclicamente si sono
presentate dopo ogni un ciclo
statisticamente di 30 anni
beh ad esempio quando sono nato io negli
anni settanta più o meno su per giù
beh c'era
un tasso di mortalità infantile del 40
per cento nei paesi in via di sviluppo
che diventava drasticamente
drammaticamente superiore se pensavamo
le zone rurali dei paesi in via di
sviluppo dove nascere magari di notte
era un grosso problema perché perché non
c'era la luce diventava molto difficile
riuscire a partorire nel buio era un po
come dire
perdonatemi la battuta dare luce prima
di dare alla luce e alla fine le
tecnologie che però venivano utilizzate
quel illuminazione nei vari posti del
mondo
i paesi più avanzati e meno bella fine
erano molto diverse ad esempio negli
stati uniti si industrializza va il gas
neon e quindi le prime lampade di questo
tipo in italia in verità si andava
ancora avanti con lampadine al tungsteno
con lampadine comunque incandescenza nei
paesi in via di sviluppo in india ad
esempio le lampade ad olio
beh se pensiamo però che dopo 30 anni ci
sono state delle evoluzioni a
quell'epoca quello che si faceva alla
fine era un po un localismo
dell'innovazione
ognuno sviluppava delle innovazioni
secondo le tecnologie che aveva a
disposizione o che in qualche modo
sviluppava nel suo paese
abita ancora il palloncino in mano vero
ok dopo 30 anni il mondo è leggermente
cambiato dopo 30 anni da quegli anni 70
sono nati i miei figli e in verità
i numeri sono magari ci sono spostati su
altre cose
in quegli anni e gli anni 2000 nascevano
due milioni di bambini prematuri in
tutto il mondo bambini prematuri vuol
dire sotto o prima e 37 settimane di
gestazione di nuovo i paesi cercavano in
qualche modo tutti quanti di sviluppare
delle tecnologie per risolvere questo
non tanto problema quanto per permettere
ai bambini ai neonati di superare il
quinto giorno e quindi negli stati uniti
all'epoca si utilizzavano delle
incubatrici quel wearable device e
quindi con delle tecnologie indossabili
che permettevano di mettere in rapporto
e in collegamento attraverso dei sensori
sofisticatissimi i parametri fisiologici
della nato insieme all'incubatrice la
stessa incubatrice veniva poi dopo in
qualche modo tolta di alcune
caratteristiche tecnologiche e
utilizzata ad esempio in italia ma la
stessa incubatrice spogliata ancora di
altre caratteristiche tecnologiche
veniva utilizzata è venduta nei paesi in
via di sviluppo come ad esempio in india
dove alla fine aveva solamente le
feature le componenti basi e quindi
quelle di creare un piccolo microclima
per il neonato
beh si è un po passati da un concetto di
localismo a un concetto che i software
istino negli anni 2000 all'epoca
chiamavano di localizzazione io sviluppo
una tecnologia molto performante con
molte cose questa tecnologia faccio un
po il down grading per poter poi creare
o applicare questa tecnologia ha dei
mercati che sono più poveri dei miei e
fra 30 anni ma fra 30 anni
in verità non so i figli dei miei figli
oi figli dei figli dei miei figli fra
altri 30 anni che tipo di sfide avranno
però in questo momento c'è un tassello
in più c'è una consapevolezza in più il
27 settembre nel 1900 del 2015 dell'anno
scorso 193 paesi delle nazioni unite
all'unanimità hanno votato una
risoluzione per adottare 17 sustainable
development goals 17 obiettivi di
sviluppo sostenibile per poter in
qualche modo si chiama agenda 20 30 per
poter in qualche modo affrontare le
sfide globali
beh questo è un'opportunità bellissima
perché vuol dire che il 193 paesi sono
tutti con mister sono tutti focalizzati
su obiettivi comuni
i 17 ed i gip però nel 2030 noi saremo 8
miliardi e mezzo
otto miliardi e mezzo di persone di cui
il 20 per cento abiteranno di sederanno
nei paesi che hanno il più alto tasso
percentuale di investimento in ricerca e
sviluppo cioè tradotto quei paesi
che stanno correndo e stanno sviluppando
tecnologie di altissimo livello di
altissimo profilo
mentre invece i paesi in via di sviluppo
beh il paese sviluppo entro il 2030
avranno un tasso di crescita per quanto
riguarda gli investimenti dice che
innovazioni intorno all'uno per cento
all'anno
non è sufficiente in verità si va a
creare un po un paradosso perché io alla
fine è come se volessi o pretendessi che
l'ottanta per cento della popolazione
del mondo adottasse delle tecnologie
sviluppate nel 20 per cento della parte
del mondo della popolazione per
affrontare delle sfide globali è un po
un paradosso se vogliamo
beh in questo allora mentre prime
continua a gonfiare il suo palloncino
sempre questo avete sempre il palloncino
vero in mano mentre lui continua a
gonfiare stavo pensando ma in effetti in
effetti è vero se è come se noi
volessimo in qualche modo affrontare
queste sfide globali avendo tanti in
back greider nei vari paesi
vi ricordate macgyver beh sì dai abbiamo
visto tutti o nell'eroe della sede della
anni 80
ve lo ricordate lui riusciva a fare
tantissime cose con poco con pochissimo
allora chi di chi di noi non ha mai
provato a smontare l'asciugacapelli a
rimontarlo e accorgersi poi di aver
lasciato nei pezzi fuori quando i
capelli funzionava lo stesso e allora
con quei pezzi in disparte si è
inventato delle altre cose per avere il
suo proprio asciugacapelli
beh è un po come faceva anche un po
macgyver o come diceva premano gonfiava
il suo palloncino beh papa sai i paesi
che cervello anno di più quelli meno
ricchi perché devono fare tanto con poco
ma ci sono degli esempi perché questa è
un'opportunità straordinaria provate a
pensare a utilizzare questa capacità di
fare tanto con poco magari con delle
tecnologie non di altissimo livello
medio ma che arrivano anche da altri
paesi ci sono degli esempi in questo
senso
beh uno su tutti è questa piccola sacca
sacco a pelo termico per i bambini dei
paesi in via di sviluppo per mantenerli
al caldo oppure questa protesi fatta con
materiali non super performanti ma che
ha sufficienti gradi di libertà per
permettere
il movimento a persone che abitano in
islam nelle periferie delle grandi città
del mondo nelle megalopoli oppure delle
nuove alghe che in qualche modo grazie a
un processo foto statico creano luce
dentro delle bottiglie di acqua oppure a
un nuovo tipo di design con i materiali
plastici biodegradabili che permettono
il trasporto d'acqua alle popolazioni
dell'africa che devono fare chilometri e
chilometri ogni giorno quindi è
un'opportunità
però questo alla fine porta a un
concetto molto importante che è quello
del glocalismo dell'innovazione ovvero
provate a pensare come io potrei in
qualche modo sviluppare delle tecnologie
che sono locali che affrontano delle
sfide locali magari in paesi poveri che
quindi devono fare tanto con poco che
quindi devono cerebellare però usando
delle tecnologie che in qualche modo li
aiutino ad affrontare delle sfide
globali
allora alla fine un po per concludere
mentre guardavo prende gonfiava il
palloncino beh però diane datemi una
mano gonfia telo anche voi provate a
gonfiare il palloncino che avete trovato
se avete avuto in mano per tutto questo
breve the talk beh sento che lo state
gonfiando bravi
alla fine mentre guardavo frank e con
chiama il palloncino in effetti pensavo
però noi alla fine la tecnologia
l'innovazione gli investimenti fare
tanto con poco
beh alla fine della fiera se vogliamo
dirla tutta
noi facciamo tutto questo per migliorare
cambiare una sola cosa che è l'unica
cosa che noi lasceremo ai nostri figli
ed è in effetti questa che è il mondo ma
se guardate il palloncino che guarda
caso avete contribuito voi a gonfiare
facendo tanto con poco come faceva
macgyver e alla fine il palloncino però
rappresenta un po il mondo e il mondo
non è né mia né tuo nel suo ma è nostro
quindi da condividere perciò quello che
vi invito a fare conclusione di questo
top e provate a passare il mondo al
vostro vicino anche
se non lo conoscete grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]